>> Greg: NBC'S SAVANNAH
GUTHRIE INTERVIEWED NICK
SANDMANN, THE RELUCTANT FACE OF
THE COVINGTON CONTROVERSY.
>> SOME PEOPLE SEE AS A YOUNG
KID WITH A SMIRK ON HIS FACE.
>> Greg: THERE IS THAT "SOME
PEOPLE AGAIN."
SOME DAY I WOULD LIKE TO MEET
SOME PEOPLE.
THEN CAME THE NATHAN PHILLIPS
CLAIM OF THE "BUILD THE WALL"
CHANT THAT APPARENTLY NO ONE
ELSE HEARD.
>> DID ANYONE SAY "BUILD THE
WALL?"
>> I NEVER HEARD ANYONE SAY THAT
AND I DON'T THINK I'VE SEEN IT
IN ANY VIDEOS.
>> AFTER REVIEW OF THE VIDEO,
NBC NEWS COULD NOT HEAR ANYONE
SHOUTING THAT HOT BUTTON PHRASE.
>> Greg: SO NO ONE CHANTED,
BUT WHAT IF THEY DID?
SOME SAY WE ARE LETTING LIBERAL
FASCIST DISCIPLE CAN BE SAID IN
PUBLIC.
THE BLACK ISRAELITES SAID THINGS
WE CAN'T REPEAT HERE.
BUT IT'S "BUILD THE WALL" THAT
MATTERS MOST.
IT'S A HOT-BUTTON ISSUE, SOME
SAY, WHICH IS MEDIA FOR LET'S
TRASH YOU.
THEN CAME THE HAT.
>> DO YOU THINK IF YOU WEREN'T
WEARING THAT HAT, THIS MIGHT NOT
OF HAPPENED OR IT MIGHT'VE BEEN
DIFFERENT?
>> THAT'S POSSIBLE, BUT I WOULD
HAVE TO ASSUME WHAT MR. PHILLIPS
WAS THINKING, AND I WOULD RATHER
LET HIM SPEAK FOR WHY HE CAME UP
TO US.
>> Greg: SOUND FAMILIAR?
YOU GO OUT WEARING THAT, CLEARLY
YOU ARE ASKING FOR IT.
BECAUSE YOU ARE A VICTIM OF YOUR
OWN CHOICES AND ACTIONS.
>> YOU NEGLECTED THEY WERE
MAINLY VICTIMS OF THEIR OWN
CHOICES AND ACTIONS.
SHOULDN'T WE DISCUSS THAT?
I WONDER IF THE HATS HAD
ANYTHING TO DO WITH THE MUTED
RESPONSE.
>> Greg: IMAGINE SAYING THAT
ABOUT A FEMINIST PROTESTER AND
HER CLOTHES.
FUNNY HOW THE MEDIA WHO CLAIMED
THEIR SPEECH IS ALWAYS UNDER
THREAT BECAUSE OF TRUMP ARE NOW
DICTATING WHAT WORDS AND
CLOTHING ARE FORBIDDEN.
THEN THEY BLAME THE VICTIM.
NOW STANDING IS EVEN HATEFUL.
>> THERE IS SOMETHING AGGRESSIVE
ABOUT STANDING THERE.
STANDING YOUR GROUND.
WE BOTH STOOD YOUR GROUND.
IT WAS LIKE A STARE DOWN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT NOW
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THAT
MOMENT?
>> I WOULD SAY MR. PHILLIPS HAS
A RIGHT TO COME UP TO ME.
I HAD MY RIGHT TO STAY THERE.
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW.
MAYBE STANDING IS THE ONLY THING
TO DO WHEN A STRANGER BEATS HIS
DRUM IN YOUR FACE BUT THEN
GUTHRIE QUESTIONED WHETHER TEENS
WOULD BE SCARED OF MALE ADULT
STRANGERS AGGRESSIVELY TAUNTING
THEM.
>> DID YOU FEEL THREATENED AT
ALL WESTERN MARKS TO GO I
DEFINITELY FELT THREATENED.
>> THERE WERE MORE OF YOU THAN
THEM BUT YOU FELT LIKE THEY WERE
STRONGER?
>> THEY WERE A GROUP OF ADULTS
AND I WASN'T SURE WHAT WAS GOING
TO HAPPEN NEXT.
>> Greg: OKAY, GET THIS.
118 IS STANDING QUIETLY, SOMEHOW
THAT IS THREATENING BUT WHEN
FOUR CRACKPOTS THREATEN YOU,
THAT'S JUST GOOD-NATURED FUN.
MEANWHILE "THE WASHINGTON POST"
WINDS AT THE RIGHT HAS SEIZED ON
THEIR SCREWUP, SO AFTER PUSHING
THIS NEAR, THEY ARE NOW BLAMING
OTHERS FOR GETTING CAUGHT.
SOME MIGHT SAY THE OUTCRY
PREVENTED THE PREZ FROM DOING
FAR WORSE.
FLOODING THE MEDIA ANALYZE THIS
MASK, I FEEL LIKE I'M WATCHING A
MURDERER DOING AN AUTOPSY ON ITS
OWN VICTIM.
IT MUST BE SUICIDE, THEY
DECLARE.
SOME SAY THEY SUCK.
ALL RIGHT, JESSE.
WE HEARD FROM THE KID.
ISN'T TIME THAT WE SEE NATHAN UP
THERE ANSWERING QUESTIONS?
>> Jesse: I THINK NATHAN NEEDS
TO GET THE SAVANNAH TREATMENT.
THIS IS THE THING, HE WILL BE
ABLE TO ANSWER HER QUESTIONS.
I DID A LITTLE INVESTIGATION
BECAUSE THE MEDIA WON'T, AND
NATHAN PHILLIPS, FRESH OFF THIS
CONFRONTATION WITH THE STUDENT,
DISRUPTED AND ATTEMPTED TO
DISRUPT THE MASS THAT D.C.'S
NATIONAL SHRINE.
HE TRIED WITH A BUNCH OF PEOPLE,
20 OF THEM, TO GO BANG DRUMS,
INVADE THE NATIONAL SHRINE
DURING MASS ON THIS DAY, AND
THEY HAD TO HAVE SECURITY LOCK
HIM AND LOCKED THE DOORS AS HE
ATTEMPTED TO GAIN ENTRY.
IT'S ALSO COME TO OUR ATTENTION
THIS GUY NEVER SERVED IN
VIETNAM.
HE WAS A MARINE BUT A LOT OF
REPORTS SAYING THAT HE WENT AWOL
FOUR TIMES AND HAD TO BE PUT IN
THE BRIG.
HE IS SAYING THAT WHEN HE
RETURNED FROM VIETNAM, HE WAS
CALLED A BABY KILLER AND SPIT
ON.
HE NEVER WENT TO VIETNAM.
PHILLIPS ALSO GAVE AN INTERVIEW
AND NO ONE HAS EVEN TALKED ABOUT
THIS.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT WHAT HE WAS
THINKING.
THIS GUY, PHILLIPS, SAID THESE
WHITE STUDENTS WERE IN THE
PROCESS OF ATTACKING THE BLACK
INDIVIDUALS.
DIDN'T HAPPEN.
THEY WERE "BEASTS PREYING ON THE
BLACK INDIVIDUALS."
ANY CALLED THE STUDENTS RACIST
AND HE SAID THE LOOKS ON    ON H
AND HE SAID THE LOOKS ON    ON E
KIDS' FACES WERE SIMILAR TO THE
FACES DURING LYNCHINGS IN THE
SOUTH.
NOW, THIS GUY'S STORY HAS
CHANGED SEVEN TIMES.
THE FACT THAT THE MEDIA BELIEVED
THIS GUY WITHOUT CHECKING
ANYTHING, WHAT ELSE IS THE MEDIA
BEING TOLD AND JUST RUNNING
WITH?
HOW DO WE KNOW?
>> Greg: IT FITS THEIR
ASSUMPTIONS.
WHAT KILLS ME, JED, IS THE IDEA,
IF YOU ARE WEARING SOMETHING,
YOU HAD IT COMING.
WE HAVE LEARNED THAT THAT'S NOT
WHAT YOU SAY TO PEOPLE.
>> Jedediah: THE NERVE TO SAY
THAT TO A KID.
>> Greg: WEARING A HAT.
>> Jedediah: THE LINE.
YOU WERE WEARING A SKIRT LIKE
THAT, YOU DESERVE IT.
IT'S CRAZY.
YOU DID THAT RESEARCH BUT THEY
ARE COUNTING ON NO ONE DOING
THAT OR YOU DO IT BUT IT DOESN'T
GET SENT OUT.
ALL THEY NEED IS THE INITIAL
CLIP AND THE JUDGMENTS TO BE
MADE.
IMAGINE IF YOU WENT OUT AND YOU
WERE AT ON MARCH YOU WERE A KID
AND YOU HAD A BUNCH OF ADULTS
SCREAMING AT YOU, SHOUTING
HORRIFIC THINGS.
I AM STILL TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THIS KID DID WRONG.
I THINK HE SMIRKED.
I SEE THAT.
MAYBE HE WAS CONFUSED.
HE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WAS GOING
ON.
HE DIDN'T ASSAULT ANYBODY.
HE DIDN'T EVEN SHOUT BACK.
HOW WOULD PEOPLE CAN SAY THAT AS
A TEENAGER, THEIR FIRST INSTINCT
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN TO SAY
SOMETHING BACK,'S TO SAY NO, YOU
ARE THIS.
THEY DIDN'T DO THAT.
THESE KIDS FOR ON THEIR BEST
BEHAVIOR FRANKLY.
I CAN'T BELIEVE WE ARE STILL
TALKING ABOUT A SMIRK FROM A KID
BECAUSE HE HAD A MAGA HAT ON.
IF HE DIDN'T HAVE A MAGA HAT AND
THAT WAS NOT A PRO-LIFE PROTEST,
THIS WOULD NOT BE A STORY.
TO >> Greg: THE LESSON I
LEARNED, I'M NEVER, EVER LOOKING
AT A VIRAL VIDEO AGAIN.
AGAIN.
IT'S SO FUNNY THAT IT'S CALLED
VIRAL BECAUSE IT'S CONTAGIOUS,
PERNICIOUS, --
>> Dana: AND IT MAKES YOU
SICK.
IT DOES MAKE YOU SICK.
REMEMBER BACK IN THE DAY BEFORE
THE INTERNET --
>> Greg: AT THE EARLY '50s?
>> Dana: IT WOULDN'T OF BEEN
AN INTERNATIONAL STORY.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A LOCAL D.C.
STORY.
MAYBE ON THE NATIONAL NEWS BUT
UNLIKELY TO HAVE EVER GONE
BEYOND THAT.
NOW THESE KIDS ARE HAVING TO GO
ON "THE TODAY SHOW" WHICH IS
QUITE INTIMIDATING.
NOT THAT SAVANNA IS
INTIMIDATING.
BUT YOU ARE BASICALLY ON YOUR
OWN THERE IN A ROOM.
YOU ARE 17 YEARS OLD.
HOWEVER OLD PS.
WHAT I READ WAS THAT THE LEFT ON
THE RIGHT WAS MAD AT SAVANNAH
GUTHRIE AFTER THIS INTERVIEW.
I'M NOT SURE WHY THE LEFT WOULD
BE NOW.
STEVE ORG I WOULDN'T HAVE
PERFORMED AS WELL AS THAT KID
DID.
HIS FIRST TIME ON TV I THINK.
>> Juan: HIS FACIAL EXPRESSION
WAS FROZEN.
LOOKED LIKE HE WAS TERRIFIED.
CLEARLY THEY HIRED A P.R. FIRM
TO REPRESENT --
>> Greg: HOW DARE THEY.
>> Juan: I JUST HAVE TO SAY I
DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW YOU MADE
THIS YOUNG MAN INTO SOME, YOU
KNOW VICTIM HERE.
>> Greg: CLEARLY NOT A VICTIM.
>> Juan: SAME BUT LET'S BLAME
THE MEDIA.
YOU AND I AGREED YESTERDAY THAT
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM THAT
SPREAD THIS.
WE DON'T KNOW WHO THEY ARE WHERE
THEY ARE FROM.
>> Greg: WE KNOW WHO
"THE WASHINGTON POST" IS.
>> Juan: THEY HAVE
INTENTIONALLY PUSHED OUT
POLARIZING VIDEOS INTENDED TO --
>> Greg: THE PEOPLE WHO PUSH
THEM ARE ALWAYS LIBERAL MEDIA.
>> Juan: LET ME FINISH.
>> Greg: I AM LETTING YOU
FINISH.
BREATHE IN.
>> Juan: IF THE MEDIA HAD
IGNORE THIS STORY.
I DON'T THINK THAN LOCAL SECTION
OF "THE WASHINGTON POST"
WOULD'VE COVERED IT.
IF THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA HAD
IGNORE THE FACT THAT THE RIGHT
AND LEFT PICKED UP ON IT, THEN
THEY WOULD SAY OH, MY GOSH.
WHY IS THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA IS
IGNORING THIS BIG STORY?
BUT IN FACT, LET ME TELL YOU.
TOMORROW NIGHT AM GOING TO WATCH
A BASKETBALL GAME.
THE BLACK ISRAELITES WILL BE
THERE SAYING RUDE THINGS TO ME
AND MY WIFE.
THEY SAY THINGS TO EVERYBODY.
PEOPLE DON'T STAND THERE AND
ENGAGE.
>> Greg: THE FIRST TIME THEY
EVER SOLVE THEM.
>> Jesse: THEY WERE WAITING
FOR A BUS TO GO HOME.
>> Greg: LET ME JUST SAY --
>> Juan: THOSE KIDS STAYING
THERE.
HE IS STARING DOWN THE
NATIVE AMERICAN GUY.
>> Jesse: THE GUY GOT IN HIS
FACE.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO?
>> Juan: YOU HAVE FOUR OR FIVE
BLACK ISRAELITES.
YOU HAVE BUSLOADS OF THESE KIDS.
SUDDENLY THEY ARE FEELING SO
THREATENED.
>> Jesse: YOU HAVE --
>> Jedediah: YOU HAVE ADULTS
AND CHILDREN.
>> Juan: BASKETBALL GAMES.
>> Greg: IF YOU WANT TO TALK
ABOUT IT, THEY HAVE THESE